CATHERINE KAPUTA: --not
even the Google brand.
And that's a very powerful
brand, as you all know.
It's one of the most admired
companies in the world,
voted most innovative company.
No, we're not going
to talk about Google.
We're here to talk about the
most important brand you'll
ever market, brand you.
And virtual branding
and social selling
is especially
important for sellers,
for sales professionals
to really understand.
Because if you don't leverage
it, as powerful as Google is,
you won't be leveraging things
that your competitors are
leveraging.
You won't be leveraging things
that your clients and prospects
are using.
So it's important, when
you think about it,
to build a brand for yourself
online as well as in person.
Social selling and virtual
branding on LinkedIn
can help you do that.
If you want to
expand your network,
shorten the sales cycle,
LinkedIn can help you do that.
Before we start, let's look at
an interesting story of a sales
person who transcended
the old world of selling
and is very successful now
in the new world of selling,
Barbara Corcoran,
who is a salesperson
in a different area than yours.
And Barbara has an
interesting story.
She moved to New
York in her late 20s.
She had 22 different jobs,
cycled through them all, more
than I even had, and started
out, went to New York City,
and established a real
estate brokerage business
with her boyfriend.
And after about six
months, she figured out
he was having an affair
with his office secretary.
So she says, I'm out of here,
and they divvy up the assets.
She gets $1,000, and she
goes to start her own firm.
As she's leaving,
he goes, you'll
never be able to
make it without me.
And she starts her own company.
She calls it the Corcoran Group.
And at this time, this
was the mid 1980s,
and it was a time that there
wasn't a lot of information
about residential real
estate prices in New York.
It was a very secretive world,
and it was run by wealthy women
in mink coats that had keys
to all the best apartments
and kept all the
information very secret.
And so Barbara saw this
hole in the marketplace,
and she thought, I'm
going to fill that hole.
Her new firm, in its first year
it just sold 11 apartments.
So she added up the sales
prices of all 11 apartments,
divided by 11, and came up with
$242,000 as the average price.
And she wrote a report that she
called "The Corcoran Report."
And she made 60 Xerox copies,
sent them to 60 reporters
at "The New York
Times," and it landed
on the front page of the real
estate section of "The New York
Times."
The lead sentence was,
according to Barbara Corcoran,
expert on high-end real estate
in New York, blah, blah, blah.
So overnight she
went from a nobody
to somebody that
had a brand, that
had a visibility
as a strong leader.
Then for her second issue
of "The Corcoran Report,"
she thought, gee, I'd
like to expand my network.
I'd like to have wealthy
people endorsing me.
And when you think of a very
famous person in New York
real estate that you would be
proud to have endorse yourself,
who comes to mind
in the '80s who's
still very prominent today?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
But also--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: No,
Donald Trump is it.
So she wanted Donald
Trump to endorse her.
So she calls his office, and
she says to the secretary,
I'm doing the second
issue of "The Corcoran
Report" on the most expensive
residential buildings in New
York City, and I'd like
to interview Mr. Trump.
And the secretary
goes, Barbara who?
And she says, well, there was
a feature in "The New York
Times."
So she said, he's very busy.
I really can't set
up an appointment.
And then she said, oh, that's
too bad, because according
to my calculation--
at that time he
was advertising Trump
Tower in the 1980s,
and he was advertising it as the
most expensive building in New
York City-- Trump Tower
is not number one.
She gets a meeting with
Donald Trump telling him
he's number two.
So she has the meeting
with Donald Trump,
and he says to her, here's how
to calculate the average sale
price.
And of course she
knew that there
were other ways of calculating
it and that by most of them
his building was
the most expensive,
but she let him convince her.
And then he said to her
at the end of the meeting,
you know, I'm running a
major ad campaign right now
on Trump Tower, and
I'll put in each ad
that it's the most expensive
residential building according
to "The Corcoran Report."
So then she became
even more successful
because she had Donald
Trump's endorsement.
So one of the things that I
want to leave you with this
you want to attach
an idea to yourself.
My first rule of
branding is you want
to attach an idea to yourself.
Barbara attached an idea that
she was a real estate expert.
And she had very
little experience,
but she attached
that idea to herself.
It was a different idea,
because at that time
no one was filling that
place in the marketplace.
So you want to attach
a different idea.
In a sea of goldfish, you
want to be a green fish.
You want to attach
an idea that's
authentic, that's something
that's true to you.
And you want to
attach an idea that's
relevant to the marketplace.
Anyway, here's my
Donald Trump picture.
This is Donald Trump's
reaction when he found out
that he wasn't going to be
the number one building.
And so he ran this ad
campaign, the most expensive
residential building
in New York City,
which leads me to my
second rule of branding.
You want to network.
You want to network
for influential people.
Marketers always
know the best way
to sell yourself is to get
other people to do it for you.
Then in the mid 1990s
during another slump
in the real estate
market in New York,
Barbara Corcoran
read that Madonna
was looking for an
apartment in Manhattan.
And at the time she didn't
have any celebrity clients.
She wanted to have them,
but she didn't have them.
She read that Madonna was
looking for apartments.
So she called all the
news stations and said,
I have a point of view on
what apartments Madonna should
be looking at, and so she
got on the evening news,
and she was introduced as
the broker to the stars.
As I said, she didn't have
any celebrity clients.
But as a result
of that interview,
she got a call the next day from
Richard Gere's agent saying,
Richard Gere wants to find
an apartment in Manhattan.
Do you think you
can meet with him?
She said, you know what?
I think I can fit
it in, which leads
to my third rule of branding.
It's all about perceptions.
Branding is all
about perceptions.
It doesn't matter who's better.
It's really what
perceptions are.
When I was a kid and people
would make fun of me,
I'd go crying to my mother.
And she'd say, forget
about what other people say
and what other people think.
What's important
is what you think.
But it's not true.
It is important what
other people think.
That was bad advice.
And branding and
virtual branding
is about building positive
perceptions for brand you.
And really branding
is about what
you do to the minds of other
people by what you're saying.
And that leads to my fourth
principle of branding.
You always want to be
expanding into new markets.
How has the market changed?
One thing that's going on in
the whole technology area,
according to Gartner 80%
of marketing tech decisions
will be made by lines
of business by 2016.
So there's a lot of
technology buyers
that aren't just
traditional IT guys that
are going to be part of it.
So thinking of new markets and
how to present yourself well
in those new markets.
So then flash forward.
Barbara sells her
business for $70 million.
You see on "The Shark Tank" now.
She's sort of brought her
brand into modern world.
She's very active on
LinkedIn and television,
other social media.
And it was interesting, because
she wrote a blog a couple weeks
ago that she did a mailing
to her clients and prospects.
And she said I got more calls
about this marketing campaign
than anything else I did.
And what was interesting
wasn't what was in the package.
It was the stamp that I used.
She was pretty well-known.
It's not something we
can do and get away with,
but she did a stamp with her
picture on it from [INAUDIBLE],
and it got everybody
talking, which
leads to my next
principle of branding.
You want to think outside in.
You want to think
of what reaction
do I want to get
from buyers, and what
do I have to do to
get that reaction.
So if you want to get
in "The New York Times,
you need to provide information.
Or if you want to be
quoted by the media,
you want to be providing
fresh information that no one
else has provided them with.
If you want to get
endorsed by Donald Trump
and you don't know
him, you need to think
of what is his mindset?
How can I get him
to take the call?
So you want to think
of who is my market,
and what do I have to
do to reach that market?
And my sixth
principle of branding
is you want to
disguise your message.
The branding world is all about
commercials that they really
go into a really detailed
explanation of what
the product is or
what the service is.
It's really all about
image, how the brand
makes you feel, the kind of
people that use that product.
So it's much more effective
to sell your story,
to wrap your brand
in a story, so
to tell stories and
do interesting things
that clients and prospects
are interested in.
And so here's Barbara today.
This is her LinkedIn profile.
She's an Influencer on LinkedIn,
so she's one of the bloggers
that they feature
along with Jack
Welch and other well-known
people, which leads me
to my seventh rule of branding.
You want to use LinkedIn to
build brand and increase sales.
Here's an interesting statistic.
64% of all corporate website
traffic comes from LinkedIn.
So it's a very powerful
area to build your brand,
because so many people look
at things there and then go
to visit a corporate website.
Facebook is decreasing.
It was 30%.
Now it's about 17%.
And Twitter is in
the teens as well.
But it's really
dominated by LinkedIn.
It's got 180 million
members, but it's
a very, very powerful
force for buyers.
So all of the changes that have
happened in the sales world
and in the marketing
world have come
about because of
the internet and how
it's transformed everything.
And we're all familiar with the
marketing funnel, the old way
of marketing and selling where
at the top it was a funnel.
There were a lot of products.
That's when
advertising took place.
And then it narrowed
down as people
went through the sales process.
And then there was a lot of
activity at the other end,
whether it was point of
purchase or one-to-one sales.
Today the image is a
double-ended focus funnel,
because clients and
prospects have access
to so much information.
They educate themselves a lot.
So it's push-pull marketing
that's taking place.
It's not just people
pushing their message out
but also clients
pulling the message in.
One of the research studies show
that 57% of the sales decisions
are made by clients,
are made by prospects
before they even call somebody
to find out more information.
So what's the mindset
of top social sellers?
There's been some studies done.
Almost 90% of them use
LinkedIn as the focus,
because that's where the fish
are that they want to get.
They put a lot of attention
into doing their profile.
Over 40% rate their
profile as well done.
So they take the time to
write a very good summary.
They focus a lot on the
headline, the visual, their job
experience.
Instead of just a
couple of sentences,
they really tell a story.
They talk in terms of framing
it almost like a business
presentation-- here
was the challenge.
Here's what was accomplished.
Here were the obstacles--
when they do it.
About 70% of them say they
spend six hours a week,
roughly an hour a
day, on LinkedIn.
So they really spend
time using LinkedIn.
They use more
capabilities of LinkedIn
than other sellers,
the top social sellers.
About half use the paid
version of LinkedIn.
Half don't use the paid
version, but half do.
And 45% claim they
get more opportunities
by using LinkedIn as well.
And here's five reasons
why top social sellers
are leveraging social.
One is that it opens
doors to other areas.
So other lines of business
that you may be interested in,
LinkedIn opens the doors.
In the old world of
branding that I talked about
with Barbara Corcoran, it
was very hard to get it.
You had to be a
very clever person,
like she was, to
get media attention.
Today LinkedIn
gives you a platform
to build your brand
on the profile.
Also it's the modern
way of doing business.
A lot of tech sellers tell
me that the smaller clients
that they're going after, after
they meet, even with the CEO,
they'll get an email wanting
to connect on LinkedIn.
So it's really kind of a
modern way of doing business.
And it really paves the way
to the C-suite and the things
that you really want to do.
And a lot of top
social sellers really
claim that it helps them not
only build their prospect pool
but also shorten the sales time.
So what is social selling
and how do you do it?
Four components of social
selling, number one is brand.
You want to build your brand.
Number two is you want
to find the right people,
you want to engage
them, and then
you want to build
relationships with them.
So let's break it down.
Let's look at step one,
building your personal brand.
An important thing to realize
is a weak online footprint
says you're a weak brand.
When people look at your
profile and not much is there,
they're going to make the
assumption that you're not
as strong as someone that has
a strong profile that utilizes
the 2,000 characters in
the summary, that tells
an interesting story, that has
a lot of activities going on.
So it's a key thing
you want to do.
And also pull strategies
where clients and prospects
are attracted to you really
require a strong brand.
They're not going to
go to a brand that
doesn't look like
it's substantial.
That's true in
the product world.
It's also true in the
world of personal branding.
So how do you figure
out what your brand is,
and how do you figure out
how to build your brand?
In the marketing
world, the first step
is we do a brand audit.
And part of the brand audit
is doing a SWOT analysis,
looking at your strengths
and your weaknesses.
The neat thing about
the SWOT analysis
is it forces you to
look at the marketplace.
What are the opportunities
in the marketplace?
And what's changing?
What are the threats?
What should I be worried about?
And when you do
the SWOT and when
you think of your strengths, you
want to frame your strengths.
So that strength, how is
that demonstrated in things
that I've accomplished
in my career?
You want to demonstrate it.
Because of this
trait, I accomplished
x relative to others.
So you really want
to frame it so
that people can understand it.
A big thing we do
in the brand audit
also is look at the competition.
Who are our competition?
What is their sales message?
What are their tactics?
So you really want to
have a gauge of what
your competitors
are doing as well.
And what it's all leading up
to is defining your value.
What is your unique
selling proposition?
And what you try to
do in all of this
is you're looking for
your differentiator.
What's different about your
brand compared to others?
And you want to be able
to answer these questions.
What qualities make you
different, even better
than others?
Unlike others in my field,
I-- fill in the blank.
The value you bring to a
business situation is x.
So let's just take
a couple of minutes.
I'd like everyone to pair up
with the person next to them
and answer these questions,
just whatever comes to mind.
You really want to be able
to own your value in terms
of building a brand.
So let's just take a few
minutes, each partner, and just
brainstorm with each other
and answer these questions.
Can I get some sharing?
What qualities
make you different?
This is the word that
worries people, even better
than other people.
Anyone willing to share what
qualities make you different?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah,
this is a good one.
Unlike others in my field.
It's very important
you answer that.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're not
recorded, just so you know.
AUDIENCE: OK.
What's my motivation?
Let's see--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Your career.
AUDIENCE: Unlike
others in my field,
I have not only worked quite
a great deal on the enterprise
side-- so I spent
15 years with Delta,
and I spent some
time with UPS as what
we would call a customer
now-- and now actually I
sell solutions to
people like myself.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: And what
advantages does that give you?
AUDIENCE: It gives
me good insight
on the things that are pitfalls
for a lot of enterprises when
salespeople come calling
and knocking on the door.
So you can say,
hey, I understand
what your challenges are.
I understand what you're
trying to accomplish.
And I also understand
you looking at me
in a way of just a
salesperson, but I'm here
to actually help and
help in these manners.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
So it's not selling
so much as helping.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: So
he understands that.
And having been a client myself
for many years on Wall Street,
a big problem with
a lot of salespeople
is they're selling too
much and not helping.
And you're under
a lot of pressure
when you're on the client side.
So salespeople that
help is very key.
Other people willing to share?
Is this a confident crowd?
Hello, yes.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm a
pain in the ass in the most
professional way.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: We support out
a lot of different sales
organizations.
So trying to get your agenda
and get your stuff done,
I think that's one
of the qualities that
makes me different.
I don't think everyone
agrees with it,
but I'm just being honest.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: The thing
is no brand is for everyone.
But you want to
stand for something.
And a lot of people
are going like it
because it's refreshing.
When you say something like
that and everybody laughs,
they think, oh, wow,
I can trust this guy.
Anyone else willing to share,
unlike others in your field?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Unlike
others in my field,
I've helped large enterprises
adopt different technologies
migrating from
older legacy systems
to cloud-based technologies.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: And how
do you get them to do that?
Because they must be worried,
like it's too radical a shift.
Will my company be
able to take this?
So how do you deal
with those kind of--
AUDIENCE: It's more focused
on the people and the business
process change versus
the technology,
so helping make
sure they understand
that the people will
get a benefit from it
and the company will
benefit from it.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And the
technology is really
just the underpinnings below.
I'm trying to help them
see the value of that.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
OK, great.
All right.
So in the branding world, the
first thing you want to do
is you're looking
for your brand idea.
You're analyzing to find
your USP, your Unique Selling
Proposition.
There are some strategies
that a lot of brands use.
So I'm going to just focus on
a couple of those strategies.
And in the branding world,
when you have a product
you explore different
ones, because you
don't know which
is going to work.
For example, when Volvo was
introduced in the United States
they were exploring a number
of different strategies.
One was this attribute
strategy around safety.
They were also exploring
an attribute strategy
around durability.
One of the other strategies
they were exploring
was a heritage strategy, made
in Sweden, Swedish engineering.
That didn't test too
well because Americans
go, Swedish engineering, duh.
But anyway, safety won out,
but it was an argument.
So let's explore a couple of
common positioning strategies
for brands that people can use
as well, and one is the expert.
Being an expert in a certain
area of business and standing
for that with clients can be a
very, very powerful strategy.
Here's Warren Buffett.
What's he an expert in?
Finance and investments.
And so he owns that position.
You really trust him.
They call him the
Oracle of Omaha.
And a tactic of an expert, if
you're positioning yourself
as an expert, is
white papers, writing
articles, trend reports, having
a point of view on the market
because you're an expert.
That was Barbara
Corcoran's strategy,
thought leader in your niche.
Industry events you're an
expert at as a panelist
or as a speaker.
So it can be a very
powerful positioning
strategy for brands.
Another positioning strategy
is attribute positioning,
and this is the most popular
positioning strategy of brands.
It's looking at the category.
What attributes are
important in that category?
Which attributes aren't
owned that I could own?
I talked before about Volvo.
They did an attribute
strategy around safety.
They made the car
more safe because they
were doing that strategy.
So it wasn't like
the chicken and egg.
This was an idea.
No one owned safety.
It was important group
of people in the market
that it was very powerful to.
So looking at the car
category, who owns ruggedness?
Who would you say,
in terms of cars?
That's another attribute.
AUDIENCE: Jeep.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK, Jeep.
If you look at
prestige, who owns that?
That's another attribute.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK, Mercedes.
So in the car category,
you see that a lot,
looking at an attribute,
looking at an adjective that's
available, and owning
that attribute.
And that can be very
powerful for people,
owning a particular attribute.
If you're in sales, it
could be a trusted adviser.
You want to own an
attribute that's
important to your
audience, so it's
a different positioning
than expert.
And the tactics here
are a little different,
because you really in
attribute positioning
go after endorsements,
recommendations.
If your attribute is customer
service or client attention,
you want to have a lot
of clients recommending
you and mentioning your
attribute so that people really
get that.
And that's a part of your
summary in your profile
is telling that story.
You want to have success
stories with your client that
demonstrates your attribute.
You want your articles
that you write
to reinforce that attribute.
So you do everything the
ties that altogether.
Another common
positioning strategy
is leadership positioning.
Every category, we look
for leaders, the number one
seller in the category.
And it's true in any area.
In sales you can be the leader
overall in sales at Google.
You could be the leader in
a particular product area.
You could be a
leader in a region.
And as a leader part
of your tactics are
you want to win awards
that you mention,
success stories for your
clients, because you're
a leader and you tell
those kind of stories.
You have metrics.
Your sales numbers were x, y, z.
You were the number one
producer, increased business,
or whatever your
metrics are going to be.
The thought leadership of the
expert that we talked about
is really on that
narrow expertise area.
The thought leader of a
leader is a much broader kind
of positioning.
And it's very powerful
because a lot of people
are very attracted to doing
business with the leader.
Can't make any
mistakes if you choose
the big leader in an area.
So it can be a very, very
powerful positioning strategy.
For every leader, we have
the against position,
which is the opposite
of the leader.
I also call it the
maverick positioning.
For every Bill Gates, there's a
Steve Jobs who is the opposite.
Steve Jobs is a classic
maverick positioning.
Here I have Richard Branson.
He's the CEO of a major company.
He doesn't look
like the normal CEO.
That's the thing.
You want to go against the
grain, look very difficult.
You do the opposite of
what the leader does.
The leader is doing x, you do y.
You position the leader,
they're big and fast and slow,
and I'm nimble and
smart and innovative.
So it's a very, very
different kind of positioning.
Often it goes with
contrarian viewpoint.
If you're doing articles, unlike
what the majority of people
are doing, I believe
you should be doing x.
So it's a very different kind
of refreshing but different kind
of idea of what
people should do.
This kind of person
is a change agent.
A big part of it is
being very innovative.
So if the market
is going this way,
you want to have
ideas that are very
innovative in a different way.
And all of these ideas, I think,
can be something that you use.
So I also want you
to take a few minutes
and explore them with the
person next to you where
you see yourself, if you
were to position yourself
in one of these.
An expert, what are
you an expert in?
And poof, here's why
I'm an expert in that
or how I could promote that.
Attribute positioning, the
attribute I want to own is y
and why I'm good at that and
how you would demonstrate that,
proof of that, certain
things that you've worked on
to demonstrate that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Well, the best
advertising is word of mouth.
So the best
advertising is always
what other people say about you.
You want them to
both be the same.
But partly what your clients
and prospects are going to say
is what you're communicating
with them to say too.
It's amazing.
A lot of advertising research,
what you say about a brand
is how people start
seeing the brand.
So it works both ways.
But you really
want to get always
in any category other people
talking about you, in terms
of how you position yourself.
--and then this against
or maverick position.
So let's take a few
minutes and just explore
these different positions
that we talked about,
the expert position,
the attribute position,
owning an important attribute
in the category, this leadership
position, or the
against position.
Where do you see yourself, just
to do a little exploratory?
Who sees a good
fit for themselves
with the expert position?
And what are you the expert in?
Can we get some sharing?
Who sees themselves
as an expert?
What's your area of expertise?
OK.
We need to mic here.
OK, great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Here you go.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: It's open.
It's open.
AUDIENCE: OK, so expert.
I lead an industry
team, and I'm also
the head of the retail industry.
So this is the
role of the people
on our team for
various industries
that publish white
papers, articles, develop
a point of view, all
that kind of stuff.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: So that's
what our team does.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
Any other people see
that as a good fit?
OK.
Who else?
We had somebody over here.
AUDIENCE: Luis?
Go Luis.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
I'm supposed to be
an expert on retail.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm still
developing these skills.
But I was thinking
that I can definitely
do a better job on LinkedIn
and other social networks
to promote my image.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that is true.
Yeah, we've been
talking about this.
AUDIENCE: Business
transformation
for the largest, most complex
customer to move them into--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
Say that into the mic,
because that's great.
Because retail is very
international now.
All these companies, retailers
that were just in one country
are expanding.
So tell us--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we were
talking about this.
Yeah.
I definitely have
some skills that I
could enhance in my profile.
The first of them is my
international expertise,
because I am from Europe.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
working in Europe but now
in the States.
So that's important, that
it's special and unusual.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: No,
it's very special,
because you have a lot
of information and ideas
that other people
want to know about.
AUDIENCE: And also--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
Tell me that part.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I've been working
in some special opportunities,
like really, really unusual
in the cloud business--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: --like moving
big financial organizations
to the cloud and
these kinds of things.
So I have that in my
profile, but I probably
can enhance a bit of it more.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: I think
everybody in this room
is an expert, being that
we come from Google.
We work differently
than anybody else.
We also have access to
Google X and everything else.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Well, part
of what you're saying, though,
is really this against
position, the maverick position,
because this is a
change agent position.
So part of what Google
stands for in my mind
and I think a lot
of people's minds
is this change agent
that's creating new worlds.
Lists of the most
innovative companies
in the world, usually
Google's number one.
So you've got that going.
So that's not an expert
so much as-- it's
very hard to be a change agent.
Companies want change
agents, but there
aren't that many people that
are that kind of thinker.
So that's a very
powerful position.
Attribute positioning, who felt
there was a strong connection
there for attribute
positioning for themselves?
OK.
And what's your attribute?
AUDIENCE: I think I've ended
up as a trusted adviser.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
That's a very powerful
one for salespeople.
And tell us why
you're thinking why
you own that, why
you want to own that
and why you do own it, examples.
AUDIENCE: I'm managing
salespeople now
and no longer selling.
And I think it comes from
selling for a number years
at big and small companies,
running my own company,
and having an
expensive education
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Now I ended
up as a trusted adviser
on the team and elsewhere.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
OK.
That's a great story.
AUDIENCE: We have
an internal way
to endorse people that
is called Peer Bonus.
It has also a financial
impact, but a small one.
So I had this idea when
I was listening to you
to use former people
that have given me
peer bonuses in the past.
So I can contact them and
say, hey, why don't you
please endorse me in LinkedIn?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: It's very
important to reach out and ask.
Anyone else for attribute,
a different attribute?
Leadership?
A leader in some area of sales?
No leaders here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about leadership.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
Give an example.
For example, I did a
paper on or an article on.
You want to be able to
tell a story about it.
So bring it to life.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So I wouldn't say
I'm an author, but I
do promote a lot of articles
about thought leadership,
leading positions, big data,
transformational technologies,
customer case studies.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK, mavericks.
Any mavericks?
People like that
position for themselves?
And how it fits in?
It's a strong
position, and I think
Google owns it, in general.
I think that's the viewpoint
people have of Google.
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: I assume that
there's a lot of people
in this room who fall
into this category just
because, as you
mentioned earlier,
we're all trying to do something
a little bit different here.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And I
think that we all
bring a very diverse
background, and a lot of people
here were at the
top of their fields
in a really diverse set of
companies or organizations.
And so they take those types
of contrarian viewpoints,
and they really use it to
leverage let's stop and think.
Just because something
is the way it's been,
does that mean it's
the way it has to be?
I think that people in this room
are exceptionally good at that.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
And innovation's an
important driver.
All right.
So what we're doing with
all of this exploration
is trying to come up with
our USP or Unique Selling
Proposition, what
makes us different.
And it's our selling idea.
So the next thing
we want to look at
is packaging your brand.
You want to think of
your LinkedIn profile
as an ad for brand you.
Who's your target audience
for your LinkedIn profile?
What are those people like?
What are your keywords?
What's your story?
You want your whole profile to
work together and tell a story,
tell the story you want
to tell about yourself.
What's your visual
identity as well?
Here's an example of a client.
Again, you want to think
of LinkedIn profile
as an ad, good picture, good
headline, strong summary
of yourself and your experience.
And if you don't
think visual identity
is important, in two
seconds or less people
take you in, whether
they meet you in person
or look at your
LinkedIn profile.
Two seconds or
less, they take you,
and they figure out
what you're all about.
Malcolm Gladwell wrote a
book, "Blink," about it.
In the blink of an eye,
we take something in.
The interesting thing
about visual identity
is what social scientists
call thin slicing.
They're remarkably accurate,
and they're very sticky.
They stick with us.
So that's why you want to
think about first impressions
and the impression that your
virtual brand gives as well.
They did studies at a
number of universities
showing students a two-second
video of a professor
before they took a
course with him or her,
and then they gave them the same
questionnaire five months later
after they took a course.
And they found that
that two-second slice
that they saw of the
professor and what
they wrote in their evaluation
was almost identical with what
they wrote after being in that
person's class for five months.
So these snap impressions
are very powerful.
They're very
powerful for people.
The other thing that's
important about visual identity
is there's a beauty premium.
And the branding world
knows about that.
That's why we spend a lot
of time in the way something
is packaged.
Something that's well packaged,
you can charge more for it.
People in tests,
they think there's
more volume in it just
because of its packaging.
It may or may not be true.
And the same is
true with people.
There was a study done
called "The Beauty Premium"
by two professors, one
a Harvard economist
and one a Wesleyan economist.
They named it "The
Beauty Premium,"
and they did a big study looking
at people and people that
packaged themselves well.
And we can all package
ourselves well,
because interesting
looking is very attractive.
The people that
packaged themselves well
were hired over people that were
less attractive or packaged.
And it had a halo effect.
Because someone
looked good, people
thought they were smarter than
people who didn't look as good.
And it had a whole halo effect
on a whole range of values,
including being kinder and
more productive and worth more,
et cetera, et cetera.
So you want to think of
how you package yourself
and here virtually on LinkedIn.
I know you've all gotten your
pictures taken at Google,
but you want to think of
the whole look of that.
And the picture's important
because LinkedIn's research
shows that your profile is 11
times more likely to be read
and looked at if
you have a picture.
The other thing we talk
about in the branding world
is having a visual
hook for your brand.
Twitter has its bird.
Every brand tries to
have a visual hook
so that it hooks in the
brand in the minds of people.
And on LinkedIn, you can use
rich media in your summary.
You can use it in your
Experience section
and in your Education section.
Here's an example from
a colleague that I know.
She has an ebook, and there's
a picture of the ebook.
She's got a little mini
slide presentation.
You're not going to put your
slide presentation that you
would give to a
client, but you could
do five slides that are trends.
Because a lot of people
are visually-oriented.
So you could do things like that
that give your profile a very
rich, robust look
rather than just text.
You could have a speaking video
or if you were at a conference,
a short clip that
people can see.
Trend reports, other
things like that, you
can have right there on
your LinkedIn profile,
put a nice cover on it.
So it gives your profile a
strong visual hook as well.
So in terms of branding, when
we're packaging the brand
there's the visual identity,
which is very powerful,
also the verbal identity.
And the first critical
verbal identity decision
we make in branding is the name.
What are we going to name it?
Google has a great name.
It has meaning to it.
It's an unusual name,
the double O, the two Gs.
A lot of people copied
the double O thing
with Google's success.
But names are important
for people too.
In Hollywood, for years
they changed their names
to make a more attractive name.
I sometimes ask people,
would Marilyn Monroe
be the icon she it is today,
the beauty icon she is today
if she had kept
her original name?
Does anyone remember
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Norma Jean.
Is Norma a pretty name?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: It's my
daughter's name.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: It's
your daughter's name.
It's a pretty name.
Well, there was a study
done of two women that
were viewed as
equally attractive,
and then there was
the same picture
shown to another group
asking about attractiveness.
The only change that was
made was half the pictures
had Elizabeth on them, and
then half had Gertrude.
Guess who wasn't
attractive anymore?
Yeah.
So names can hurt you.
The other name you want to
think about from a branding
perspective is how do
you label yourself?
What do you call yourself?
That can help you
or hurt you too.
And we don't take our own name.
We don't give ourselves
our own names.
But the fact of the
matter is unusual
names are a real
benefit on the internet
because you can own
your name, and you
want to try to own
your name, dot com.
Own your name.
LinkedIn slash your name.
It's easy to change that.
But another important name
is how do you label yourself?
How do you describe
what your job is?
And that can help you or
hurt you was well too.
There was a study done
showing people clips
of a video of a
professor, same clip.
Half of them labeled it
as humanistic psychology
professor.
And then the other group
saw the same video clip
with the label
statistics professor.
What do you think they
said about the professor
when the label was
humanistic psychology?
More interesting,
thoughtful, he'd
be fair in grading,
blah, blah, blah.
What do you think they said
when he was a statistics
professor, the very same clip?
AUDIENCE: Boring.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Boring.
And he'd be a tough grader.
I don't like him.
Very same thing.
So you want to think of
how do you label yourself.
Some companies, it's hard to
tell what somebody does when
you read their job
title, so you want
to translate that in
your LinkedIn profile
so the target audience,
the prospects you're trying
to reach can understand
what it is you do.
The other thing we think
about in the branding world
as we talked about a visual
hook is having a verbal hook,
owning a word.
Volvo we know.
Who owns Search?
So we think of owning a word,
a phrase, a name, a story.
What's her phrase?
AUDIENCE: Lean in.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Lean in.
She could have named her book
"The Woman's Guide to Success."
but that wouldn't have been
as smart from a branding
perspective, because
she gave it a name that
could be a mantra, that could
be calling, a rallying cry,
just like Google has
become a name for Search.
Let's google somebody.
So owning a word
is very powerful.
And writing that
book with that name
made her a mega
business celebrity.
She may have been well-known
at Google when she worked here,
and she may have been well-known
in certain communities,
but now she's a global star.
So it's very powerful.
And you want to think
of what your word is
and what your phrases are
and use them in your profile
and in your
conversation, because it
can be a very powerful
positioning idea.
All right.
So let's explore couple
of ways of approaching it.
I know you've been
working on your profiles.
I'm going to talk about
three ways of approaching
the headline for your
LinkedIn profile.
One way to go is a
keyword headline.
Think of keywords
that people would
use to find somebody like
yourself that you want
to own in the minds of others,
so global executive, supply
chain operations, Six
Sigma black belt-- it's
a little in more
tangible experience--
ROI, outperformance,
strategic leader.
So these are all
keywords that somebody
might look for in
finding this person
or finding somebody
like them so they
would come up and
search on LinkedIn.
Another way of going is a
power statement headline,
helping companies translate
business goals and ideas
into operational reality
and positive ROI.
This is the same person I was
doing the keyword headline
for I wrote a power
statement headline for.
And another way
to go is a hybrid.
So maybe begin with
a power statement
and then have your keywords
so that people can find you.
I have a little handout here
that I'm going to pass around,
and it has an exploration
of these three headline
approaches-- So if you
can take one and pass
them along-- and also
a section to write down
the keywords that you
own or want to own.
So take one and pass them down.
I'll pass some over here.
I've got some extra ones here.
So look at what
your keywords are.
And when you're thinking of
keywords, try to be expansive.
So have as many keywords that
might be useful for your brand.
This is just page one
we're going to look at.
And so the first thing
you want to think about
is this section number
two, the keyword headline,
the power statement,
the hybrid headline.
And the headline on
a LinkedIn profile
is very similar to a tweet.
It's 140 characters, roughly,
so it's like a long sentence.
So explore what would
work best for you.
How can you improve
your LinkedIn headline
so that it's a stronger
statement about who you are?
And some people
add some elements
to it that are interesting,
like humanitarian
at the end or something like
that, that dimensionalizes them
in a different way.
So you want to look for ways
to stand out and be different.
So let's focus just
on page one here,
defining who your
target audience is.
And I want you to look at it a
little bit as a psychographic
of your audience, so not
just certain kinds of people
you're pitching.
You can define them
in job function.
But also what's their mindset?
What's on their mind?
And then put together
your headline
that would most appeal
to that target audience.
And let's begin exploration
of your keywords,
the different keywords
you'd want to own.
Any sharing of headlines?
Somebody?
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
That headline, I think,
is terrible, personally.
But I wrote "transformation
consultant to the Fortune 500."
Is transformation
a hackneyed term?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
consultant's a stretch.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
What do people think?
AUDIENCE: I think the word--
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
consultant's a stretch?
AUDIENCE: --consultant
is a stretch for you.
AUDIENCE:
Transformative dictator.
AUDIENCE: We were
calling him Hollywood.
AUDIENCE: You were giving him
crap about being a wiseass?
Holy mackerel.
Is that a hackneyed term?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I
don't think it is.
And I think one of the
things that research shows
is that there's a
move to new buzz words
and that it's important
to use some of them,
because people are
going to be using them.
You don't want in your headline
hackneyed stuff, obviously,
but I think it's good.
What do other people think?
You've got to think of
your target audience.
Because it makes me think,
if I were to read that, wow,
what are the transformations?
Do I know about them all?
I'd like to learn
more about that.
Nobody else is saying that.
So to me it's
different and relevant.
AUDIENCE: I would think about
how you're transforming,
by being innovative,
disruptive, creative.
What are the things that
you're doing differently
in those transformations?
Because to your point,
we sell this every day,
so it's probably feeling
that fatigue of that word
transformation.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But where do you put
that other information?
I would think that doesn't
go in the headline.
I would put it into the profile.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: The
most important message
should be in the
headline, because people
aren't going to go on.
But then after that, it's
the summary, particularly
the first two paragraphs because
they're all above the fold.
They're all on that initial
screen people going to see.
And then they'll scroll down
if they like what they see.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So how long should
the headline be?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: It
can only be on LinkedIn
like 140 characters.
It's like a tweet.
AUDIENCE: Twitter?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
I have statistics
that show that
the way they do it
is headline, visual,
and then if they
like that they read the summary.
And then if they
like that, then they
go on to look at other things.
So that's kind of the flow.
All right.
So then you get to the summary
part of your profile, which
is your brand story told
in a narrative format.
You want to give
examples, not just
talk about functional
responsibilities.
But think from a
client perspective
of interesting things you've
done and the benefit to them.
Give examples.
Here's a profile, again, dealing
with different experience.
One of the things
to think about too
is to creatively use the
Publications and Projects
section, because
that's a section where
you can have links.
So you can have links
to a landing page
or links to a
website where people
can read articles
and things like that.
So again, it's a way
to create interaction.
And the whole thing
about social media
is this whole idea of
creating-- and we'll
get more into that
later-- interaction
so people are
interacting with you.
Here's the LinkedIn
profile checklist.
You want, ideally, to have a
customized URL with your name
on it, a good picture,
strong headline they conveys
your USP that connects
with your target audience,
a summary, your career
story with a client benefit.
And that takes some
time to put together.
And that's something
you might want
to mold as new things happen in
your industry and environment
to change it.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
All the statistics
I've seen on LinkedIn shy
away from doing anything other
than a headshot.
But you want a headshot that
communicates well with people,
that you look friendly, you look
interesting, you look smart,
somebody they want to work with.
But there's a lot of negative
statistics about group shots
or vacation shots
or things like that.
And it's a small picture.
The picture area isn't
that big on LinkedIn.
AUDIENCE: If you're going
to be different, right now
every single person here has
the same stinking picture
of a blue background,
and it just kind of looks
a little-- I don't know.
Just when I see someone
in a context of presenting
or I see someone with a picture
of their spouse or someone,
I don't know, it just makes
me think they're different.
It humanize them a little bit.
But I don't know the statistics.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
That's one of the things
about using all
these other things,
so if you have a video
or things like that,
because it humanize the brand.
So if you have a little speaking
video or things like that,
it humanizes the brand.
I think having
everybody in the company
look the same isn't
smart and also
doesn't really
connect with Google.
Because Google is
different, right?
But the group thing, people
want to see your face,
but a different kind of look.
All right.
We're going to take
a five-minute break.
This is the end of part one.
So we're going to get into how
do you find people on LinkedIn,
how do you engage them, how
do you build relationships.
So we'll get into the
nitty-gritty of social selling
next.
--a passive strategy.
You're going to put
your brand online,
and people will read it.
But we also want to talk about
you don't want to stop there.
How can I use LinkedIn for
social selling and branding?
So what kind of
actions can you take?
And so step two,
we're going to talk
about is finding
the right people,
how to use LinkedIn to
find the right people.
We've all heard of 6
degrees of separation.
Well, on LinkedIn and
Facebook, it's 4.74 degrees.
They did a major study globally.
Facebook got a lot
of attention with it.
Even reaching people
in remote Siberia,
they got there in
less than five hops.
So it's really a way
to connect easier
with more people
using the internet
and using LinkedIn
and social media.
And the way I see it
in terms of a network,
there are four key
networks that you
want to think of developing.
Your strategic network
includes mentors, sponsors,
people that you know
that connect you
with a lot of other people,
what Malcolm Gladwell
calls connectors.
And that group also is allies.
Reid Hoffman, the CEO
of LinkedIn, in his book
"The Startup of You"
talks about his network.
And he's got this
band of brothers,
allies, guys at
different companies,
non-competitive that
are friends with him,
and they all text each other
with ideas and text each other
try this or try that.
So they've got a group of
peers getting information
that you can't really get from
a mentor or a sponsor, who
are generally more
senior people.
He's got this band of allies.
And in this strategic
network, these
are people that have
strong career impact
and also have strong
relationship strength.
So they're all
people on LinkedIn
and that would be
first-degree connections.
But another very important
network is this core network.
Again, it has very
strong career impact.
These are people that are your
colleagues at your company,
at Google, but also people in
the industry, your clients,
and prospects.
And some of them will be
first-degree contacts.
Some of them will be people
that are second-degree contacts
that you don't know that well.
And one of the goals that
you want to do on LinkedIn
is move more people
from second-degree
to first-degree contacts.
Because when they're a
first-degree contact,
you can have unlimited
messaging with them, et cetera,
and you have access to
who their network is.
So that's sort of
part of the strategy
is moving more people into
first-degree contacts.
Now another group that's
an important network
is what I'm calling soft links.
These are people that
you don't know well.
But they can be
valuable just the same,
because they're
often useful when
you have a particular target
in mind or things like that.
So they're people that
you don't know well.
And then bottom
right, I'm calling it
a grassroots network.
These are people that are
close family and friends.
Again, not high career impact,
but very strong support system
just the same.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What about the idea of knowing
or be able to speak for anyone
you're connected to or
being willing to endorse?
So do you want to
connect to people
whom you don't know
well enough to know
if they're high quality?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
People have different
philosophies of that,
and I'm curious what
you people find works.
I think it's kind of
divided down the middle.
We're going to look at some of
the habits of super sellers.
But there are
people that are very
open networkers
and accept anyone.
And you can endorse anyone.
You put your skills and
expertise on LinkedIn,
and people can endorse
you in those categories.
But also on LinkedIn, other
people can see your profile
and put new skills and
endorse you in them.
And a lot of people that endorse
me, I don't know who they are.
So maybe-- I don't know.
It's kind of a
philosophy, and I think
the jury is still out
what the way to go is.
And as I say, super sellers,
they're kind of divided down
the middle from people who only
build a network that's really
what I'd call genuine, i.e.
people that they know, whereas
other people are more open
about it, figuring that
maybe I'll find a connection,
I'll find a way to connect
and it'll be useful to me.
Yes.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Not to be a
maverick [INAUDIBLE]
but I think with a harder
question to your same point
about people who
are endorsing you
who you don't know who
can't speak to your skill
set, why-- I'm from
the East Coast too,
so it's a bit different.
I struggle with taking
LinkedIn as a credible source,
because you can sort of
make up what you are.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: What's your response?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: You
take what as a-- I
didn't understand the question.
AUDIENCE: Well,
just the whole idea
of people that you don't
know endorsing you.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: So why should
we take it seriously?
We can make up like
what it says we do.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: LinkedIn
introduced endorsements
last year, because
the fact of the matter
is not a lot of people
write recommendations.
And a recommendation
is something
you have control over.
A recommendation doesn't get
posted unless you like it
and agree to it and say yes,
and then it gets posted.
And you generally ask
people to recommend you,
or you recommend them, and
they offer to recommend you.
The endorsements they did
because all you have to do
is click on the plus
button next to a skill,
so it's very easy
for people to do.
But you don't have control over.
So yes, do I think
people in the know
don't take endorsements
that seriously
because they know that?
But other people
might look at somebody
and they see 50 endorsers in
each of these key categories
and think, oh, well,
this person's somebody.
But yes, people in the
know know that endorsements
aren't that real.
So that's what
matters a lot more
is getting recommendations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: I endorse all
of my executive customers
as a nicety.
And it goes a mile.
It's amazing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I think it's easy for a
lot of people [INAUDIBLE].
There's a little bit
more poetic license
in saying what your job is.
But I struggle with [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I agree.
There's no quality control.
But I also think not
only is it a nice thing
to do to clients or
prospects, but I also
think that when you look
at somebody's profile
and they have a lot
of endorsements,
whether you know that
anybody can do it, you think,
well, they're somebody
versus somebody
that has almost nothing.
You have to realize people
make these snap judgments.
But yes, I think people in the
know know that endorsements,
you have no control over
it, and a lot of them
are from people who knows
why they're doing it,
but they're doing it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
They may see value in evaluating
you based on what's out there.
So even if you don't
see it, you have
to realize that you may be--
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Can I tell you?
I think this is a key point.
I agree with him.
A lot of people aren't
going to realize
that any Tom, Dick,
and Harry can do that.
But look, oh, this person's
been endorsed a lot.
They're going to think
you're better than somebody
that hasn't been endorsed a lot.
So I don't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: No, exactly.
AUDIENCE: So a good example is I
was endorsed by my optometrist.
It kind of caught
me by surprise,
because he's a good friend of
mine, and he endorsed me for--
AUDIENCE: He spends
a lot of money--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, no.
He actually--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: He
wants you to come in.
AUDIENCE: He is on Google Apps.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
But as far as him endorsing
me for a specific data
center or a cloud
skill, I'm not really
sure what that value might be.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Can
I tell you, I have--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I need
glasses to be a visionary.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Can I tell you,
I have a number of
people like that
too that I know who they
are and I'm wondering,
why are they even bothering,
because they don't know me
professionally.
But some people, they like
to do it, and that's it.
But I think ultimately
it's a positive,
because there are enough people
that are going to look at it
and think, this person
is better than somebody
that doesn't have many.
But what really counts
is recommendations,
so somebody taking
the time to write
a few sentences about you.
That really counts,
particularly if it's
a high-level endorsement
too, that they
have a good title
at the client side.
That works wonders, because
the other potential clients
and prospects are going
to say, oh, this person
spent the time to
write a recommendation.
That's what's really
going to count.
All right.
So what the power
of LinkedIn is is
the power of the second degree.
It's this whole area.
It's not who you know
but who do they know.
So that's the big
thing that LinkedIn
gives you is this
ability to look
at the network of your
first-degree contacts
and who do they know.
And again, kind of forming what
I said Reid Hoffman's big thing
is, this band of brothers,
people that help each other.
Oh, I know so-and-so
there, I can introduce you
to that person, and vice versa.
So the big thing is
the old way of doing
business is who do
I know at Company X?
The new way is who
does my network know
and how can I
leverage that knower?
The whole thing's
about LinkedIn.
And I think a smart way to
network is this whole idea.
You want a broad network,
because a lot of business
can come from people
that you don't
know that well or maybe
aren't that prominent.
So you want it broad, but
you want it selectively deep.
You can't be deep
with everybody.
But you want to be with the
kind of clients and prospects
that you're going after,
because more people that
fit that bill will know
other people like themselves.
So that's why that
strategy is important.
And also this statistic
that I have here
is a new research study showing
that there are 5.4 decision
makers involved in each
B2B decision process.
So you want to influence
the other people that
are part of that
decision process as well.
And so LinkedIn can
be a very good vehicle
for helping you do that.
So how do top social
sellers use LinkedIn?
About half of them sign up
for the premium product.
How many people
here have premium?
I guess you all do, right?
OK.
So it's divided down
the middle here.
What are people's opinion
that have the premium?
What do you think of it?
Sales Navigator, who's using it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
You want to pass the thing over?
The advantages that
you see from it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I have premium.
And I don't know if Julia
does, the director of media
and high-tech, as well.
Because we've been doing some
enterprise-wide industry,
thought leadership kind
of things on LinkedIn,
and there's so many
things that you
can do that I wasn't even aware
that you can do with creating
contact lists directly
from other companies,
just continuing to drill down.
It's almost like a pivot
table that you drill down
until you get to the person
that you want to get it.
Plus you get limited
on the number of mails
that you can send.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right
AUDIENCE: Inviting
contacts, there's
just too many
limitations when you're
trying to do something
across-- at least for me--
the enterprise.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
So it gives you access
to third-degree con-- OK.
Another comment?
AUDIENCE: You need an
enterprise license, though,
because it's pricey.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
LinkedIn made a killing
on the recruitment market,
and their whole
focus now is sales.
And it's pricey.
Get all your sellers
on that monthly thing--
AUDIENCE: One thing
I was hoping we
would get from you is
the settings in LinkedIn
are very complex.
When you said
endorsements, the reason
I think people endorse you--
and John mentioned it to me--
is so that their feed shows
that they endorsed you.
Basically, it helps
their own feed.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And then
all the settings
that you have around privacy and
what degree of people can see,
I was hoping maybe you would
share some of those [INAUDIBLE]
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I'm
going to get into that.
Yeah, I'm going
to get into that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
One more thing.
So a lot of it's been focused
on discovery and access.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Not to be
arrogant, but the brand takes
us quite a ways,
if you'd imagine.
And one of the things I'm
looking to also understand
is if we have contact, an
establish relationship,
how can we better utilize
some of these tool
sets to influence that decision
beyond just meeting new people
to influence and sell through.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
OK.
I'm going to be getting
into some of that,
so we can go into
that and then talk
about more when we get there.
But anyway, top social sellers,
about 50% of them use LinkedIn.
You get a lot of advantages.
You get premier search filters.
You get access to third-degree
contacts, Leader Builder
system.
There's also this team
link that you can find out
who other people at
your company know.
And that's something that
you have to opt in for.
So in the privacy,
have to sign up for it.
And if you don't
sign up for it, you
can't see likewise who other
people in your company know.
So they kind of
penalize you for that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah,
but you get all of who
viewed your profile.
Because if you don't
have the premium product,
you just see, like, five, and
the rest they don't show you.
It's a blank face.
So if you did
that, you'd see all
who's viewed your profile,
which could be interesting,
because it could be prospects
looking at your profile
or competitors, et
cetera, et cetera.
So you see all the names of
who's looked at your profile.
AUDIENCE: The idea of creating
specific industry groups
on LinkedIn--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I'm
going to get to that.
I'm going to get to that.
But there are a lot
of ways-- How many
groups do people belong to here?
A lot?
A ton?
You can do 50.
So how many belong to 50?
OK.
A lot of you belong to 50.
And how many people here
have set up their own group?
OK.
On LinkedIn.
We're going to get into that.
I'm going to get into
that, because it's
a strategy that
certain sellers do.
And what they often
do is look at groups
that have their prospects
and have their clients
and join that group.
When you join a group, you can
see the list of other members,
and you can message
them directly.
But what sellers do if
they have a niche market
is they start their
own group that's
related to the other group
with a different twist,
and then they reach out
to the people in the group
to join their group.
And there you've got
your own little forum
for communicating with
people on an ongoing basis.
But it has to have a little
different twist to it.
And also, you might want to have
a little small group of people
that are maintaining it,
because it takes some time
to put in articles yourself
and get conversation going
and invite people to join.
But certain sellers
have used it,
and it's a very
powerful strategy
because you've got
people in a group,
and you're positioning
yourself as the thought
leader of that group
by being part of it,
by starting the group, and
keeping a discussion going.
And people have found it as
a very good tool for building
business, converting, building
stronger relationships.
So it's looking at
what kind of group
would your prospects or
clients be interested in that's
not out there, and who are those
people joining those groups
and inviting them to join yours?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: One of
things that on the team
we've been talking about is
how do we move from an outreach
where we do a one-touch
or kind of a campaign type
to more of a continuous
conversation with prospects,
right?
It would be interesting to
hear how we can actually
used LinkedIn to continue that.
Because I think
even after a sale
and once we're in an account,
that continuous conversation
piece is really important now.
It's a differentiator.
Typically, the past has being
campaign, outreach, and step
away.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Yeah.
I'm going to get into that.
And that's a key
thing to think about.
Because having been
on the client side,
one of the problems is a lot
of people sell you something
and then they disappear.
So there's kind of the romance
period, and then they're gone.
And clients kind of resent that.
So it's very important to
have a vehicle for doing that.
And I'm going to go over
some ideas on doing that.
You can do that
with a group too,
having a group that carries
on the conversation.
But there's a number
of ways to do that,
so I'm going to get into that.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I know when I see a certain
number of whatever you want
to call it, activity,
coming through on my feed
from a particular
person-- I know
of one individual in
particular that posts
nothing but endorsements,
nothing but recommendations,
nothing but articles
over and over
and over again every single day
to the point where I don't even
think they do anything
other than look at LinkedIn
all the time.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there is there a
tipping point where you lose
credibility because all you're--
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Oh, I think so.
AUDIENCE: --doing
is using LinkedIn?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And where is the
philosophical balance of using
this for a real tool versus
using it as a Facebook
alternative, and then
it carries no value,
and you devalue
everything you do
because you're in it so much?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
I think we all have
somebody like that.
And I think that you've got to
think of branding and a brand.
You want to build an
image for yourself,
you want to build
a conversation,
engagement, but you
don't want to be annoying.
And if you're annoying, nobody
wants to do business with you.
It's just like any brand.
So I think there's a
fine balance there.
Is there are a number?
I think you have to sense that.
But yeah, there's certain
people that I get updates
from every day and that
endorse a million people
and all this stuff goes through.
You could block those
people, by the way.
But it's annoying.
And so you have
to think about it.
Yes, LinkedIn can
work against you.
But I think also there's a
danger not using LinkedIn
because your clients
are using it,
your prospects are using it, and
your competitors are using it.
So you want to use it to build
a positive image for yourself
and build positive
relationships and nurture them,
but you don't want to be a pest.
And some people, I wonder
where's the day job?
Because it's so annoying.
So it's a fine balance, and
you have to figure that out.
What's a good amount
of communication?
And a lot of it is
based on this whole idea
of who is your target audience
and what kind of relationship,
what kind of communication
would be effective with them.
And if you're bombarding
people, then you
devalue the whole thing,
and you're a nuisance,
and they don't want to
do business with you.
All right.
So what do top sellers
value in terms of LinkedIn?
Researching people
and companies is
by far the dominant one,
this whole idea of leveraging
second-degree contacts
and who they know.
There's more detailed ways
to connect on LinkedIn.
You can leverage your
company's contacts.
There's stories of articles
written about this that they
found out through LinkedIn that
an admin person's uncle was
a CIO at a company,
and they wouldn't
have found that
connection otherwise.
So there's a lot of
things that can help you
with maintaining
relationships, and we'll
get into more detail
in a little bit.
Electronic word of mouth.
Word of mouth is the most
important kind of advertising,
getting other people
to advocate for you.
And LinkedIn gives you
vehicles for doing that.
The most-used features are
who has viewed my profile.
71% of the top sellers, that's
their most used-feature.
People you may know, groups,
direct messaging is also cited.
Top sellers in terms
of LinkedIn groups
tend to belong to 30 groups,
whereas 36% overall just belong
to 9 or 9.
A lot of them join
alumni groups, too,
which I've found
to be very helpful.
There's something
about people that
went to the same school that
will help you in ways that I
haven't seen with
other kinds of things.
So that can be an
important one too.
Target industries,
obviously, functions.
They work the Members page.
They start looking at
who the members are
and how they can work that to
build relationships with them.
They join groups strategically.
They look at who their
hot prospects are,
what groups are they
in, join those groups,
and trying to be part
of the conversation
and build a
relationship that way.
And if that person posts
questions, responding to them
and getting a sense of what
they're interested in through
means as well.
You can follow conversations
of interest on groups.
You could set up
a follow for that.
So here I'm isolating six
search secrets of super sellers,
according to research
that's out there.
One, they use the
Advanced Search feature
to establish winning
search parameters.
They save that search
and create alerts
so that when anything
changes within that group
that they've targeted they get
an automatic update about it.
So it's an easy way to
see who's new to that that
meets those parameters that
weren't on the list before,
et cetera.
Browse the network
of your network.
You can do this with
first-degree contacts only.
And they have a feature that you
can do this automatic introduce
with LinkedIn.
But I think what a
lot of people don't
realize is when you use
that the recipient sees
the email that you wrote to your
first-degree contact as well
as the message that
you're writing to them.
So I think it's smarter to
really pick up the phone,
and if somebody's a
first-degree contact, send them
an email directly
and say, I see you're
a first-degree contact
with so-and-so.
And make it a positive thing,
not I want to sell to them,
but we've sold similar
product to another company
that really I think they'd be
interested in learning more
about, and do you
feel comfortable
introducing me personally?
It's much better if there's
a personal introduction
through email rather than using,
I think, the LinkedIn device.
Number three is you
want to check out
viewers of this profile also
viewed and people similar to.
Now this is something
that top super sellers do,
and it could give you
ideas of other people
that could be good
leads for you.
Likewise, check out who's
viewed your profile.
Super sellers also do
active company searches,
advanced search by
name or by parameters.
And when you do a
company search like that,
it'll list the people
that you're first-degree
connected with, the top five.
You can follow a
company, and you
can view people who viewed
this company also viewed.
So it's an easy way to
keep track of all of that.
Super sellers also use
Groups strategically.
They join groups that
prospects have joined.
They join groups of people that
have access to top prospects.
So if you have a CIO
target or a C-level target,
you can join groups
that suppliers
belong to or media people
or customers of theirs
to build relationships and
then move to the next level.
You can check the
group's About section,
and it'll tell you who
what kind of members
are in the group, how
active the group is,
the seniority of
them, the location.
And then, as I said, there's
a group of super sellers--
and we'll get into
more detail later--
that formed their own group to
sort of develop their thought
leadership and also
develop relationships.
And a key thing that
super sellers do too
is they're easy to reach.
They're easy to find.
They have a lot of
keywords in their profiles,
so they're easy to find.
Their title is something
that people can understand,
or they changed their title so
people understand who they are
and what their function is.
You can easily put contact
information in your profile,
if you want.
You can put your direct
email address, if you want,
so that you're easy to reach.
So step one is you want
to build your brand.
Step two is you want to find the
right customers for yourself.
And step three is
about engagement.
So how do you engage these
people and get a dialogue going
and build a relationship?
And the first thing
you want to think about
is who is your target audience?
So that point I was making
earlier, who is your audience?
What reaction, what action
do I want them to take?
And what do I have to
do to get that reaction?
And having been a corporate
person in the marketing
area, the CIO target,
in my opinion,
is very different
from the CMO target,
if you're branching out
into these other areas.
And according to Gartner, 80%
of marketing tech spending
will be in LBOs in
two years' time.
So it's an audience
to think about.
A lot of tech
companies are going
after other areas
of the C-suite.
And the CIO, in my experience
working on Wall Street,
they were more risk-adverse
than marketing people,
and they didn't want
to see a lot of change
and upset the system, a
much more traditional kind
of person, so a
different kind of sell
than a CMO who is always charged
with what are you doing next,
what kind of
exciting new things.
Or the CEO was always
calling [INAUDIBLE], oh, I
talked to this other
CEO at this company,
and this is what he's doing.
Have you thought of trying that?
So it's always
what's new and what's
innovative to bring in new
customers for the company.
And now so much of the
marketing is technology-based
because of the whole
importance of the internet
and digital media and the whole
importance of social media.
If I'm going to be judged on it,
I want to control the budget.
So that's why so much is
moving into marketing and LBOs.
Right now a lot of it
is smaller business,
but I think it's
going to be growing.
And a key thing you want to
think about in this whole area
of how do you engage your
target audience is you
always want to be
connecting with them,
not annoying them, but
connecting with them
in a meaningful way.
But a big thing
in branding today
is emotional branding,
understanding
what your clients and
prospects are thinking about,
what their problems are,
what their mindset is,
and connecting with that
in an emotional way.
Much more powerful
than rational arguments
are connecting with
people emotionally.
Just think when
you meet somebody
that you have a mutual
friend in common.
There's quick rapport that's
established because you
both have this bond with
somebody you both know.
I'm doing this
whole always series.
So you always want
to be connecting.
You always want to be
tracking competitors.
This is a new thing that
LinkedIn introduced about two
weeks ago, and it's a new tool,
tracking companies on LinkedIn
and how important
different companies are.
And here it shows you've got
some 500-pound gorillas here
on LinkedIn, Microsoft,
IBM, Oracle, HP, Google.
This was done by
looking at the target
audience of these companies.
And this is a high-tech
one, and they've
done it for every industry.
So you can see
the companies that
are spending a lot on
content on LinkedIn,
that have a lot of employees,
that are engaged on LinkedIn.
They just posted this
a couple days ago.
So what they're trying
to do, obviously,
is to get the companies that
aren't as strong on LinkedIn
to get a stronger position, get
more of their people involved
with LinkedIn, to also get more
involved with corporate ads, et
cetera, et cetera.
So it measures all of that, all
of the people at a company--
yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: No, no.
That was my point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
We heard a rumor
a little while ago
that if you link with
somebody-- for example,
if I link with somebody
from Microsoft--
can they then see everybody I'm
linking with from that point
on?
What do they see?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're a
first-degree connection.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I heard
that they were actively
doing that to see who
we're connecting with.
AUDIENCE: Of course they are.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
should we do about that?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Then
you can't connect--
AUDIENCE: Don't connect
with anyone from Microsoft?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
But they will see that, yes.
They will see that.
And yes, you can
see LinkedIn has
been a big strategy
of Microsoft and IBM
and these other companies.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Yeah, so you've
got to think about who the
first-degree connections are
going to be.
You've got to think about who
your first-degree connections
are going to be, because
they would have access
to your network.
Right.
And this is important, because
from an advertising standpoint
visibility for a brand
is very important.
Google has a
fabulous reputation,
but this shows you
that you're being out
communicated on
LinkedIn vis-a-vis
some of your major competitors.
And it's important because
in the branding world
we measure visibility.
We measure spending.
We measure attitude and
awareness of different brands.
And generally the brands
that spend the most
are the most well-known.
And there's a real premium
to being well-known,
because if you're well-known
as a brand people think
you're better than a brand
that's not as well-known.
Now these are all equally
well-known companies.
But people, they're
getting more messages
from some of your
competitors, and so that's
why all of you being
involved in a bigger way
is going to help
that score as well.
And the other thing, you
can follow companies.
And I think you should follow
your company, obviously,
but your competitors.
You can see here there's
more people following Google
than are following Microsoft,
in spite of all their spending
and activity on LinkedIn.
And this is part
of the new report
that LinkedIn is giving out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: What?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Oh, right.
She and I connected.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
Oh, really?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
No, she was telling
me about that.
Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
And by the way, for Patricia,
not only did she and I connect,
but then she introduced me
to somebody, a friend of hers
at another company.
So she made that
little gift to me,
so that I think
that was very smart.
But yeah, it shows new people
who you're connected to,
new people that you're connected
to, et cetera, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: I think a lot of
people following Google,
though, are looking for jobs.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: That's probably why
our numbers are much higher.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Mm hmm.
I think it's consumer.
I think you're right.
Yeah, I think it's consumer.
And I think that it has such a
powerful brand with everybody.
But really for young people,
it's the place to work,
innovative, et
cetera, et cetera.
And I have to say, your image
lives up to your billing,
walking through this
building myself.
So it's true.
So you always want
to be on trend.
And a new thing that
LinkedIn is doing
is this Trending Content tool.
So it tells you can
do each industry.
And what are the hot topics in
the auto industry on LinkedIn?
What are the hot topics
in the retail industry?
What are the hot topics of
CMOs, et cetera, et cetera?
The most read and passed
along and stuff like that.
A big question is, how do you
keep an ongoing relationship?
Well, you want to
be posting articles
on things that are on-trend.
You want to be on-trend,
the latest ideas.
So you want to have a pulse of
what people are interested in.
And LinkedIn now has
a tool, as I said.
It was just introduced.
OK.
Question here?
AUDIENCE: So one thing we've
talked about is being on-trend.
But what value do you see
for not following the trend?
Because I always see on
my on LinkedIn 10 people
post the same article.
And to me, that's a
lot less interesting
than the one person
who posts something
that's a little different.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Well, I agree with you.
here's the thing.
In branding, the first
person to post on a topic
kind of gets the
benefit, because they're
the leader, the
first out of the box.
There's a tremendous
premium for being the first.
That's another
positioning strategy
that I didn't get into.
But being the first can
be-- but all the follow-ons.
What you want to do is be
on-trend with a difference,
with a different perspective.
So you don't want to
be rehashing old news.
But say it with
the different twist
on it, a different
interpretation.
A big thing that clients are
interested in the B2B market
is your thought process, how
you think about something.
And Google already
has this image
of super innovative,
the latest thinking.
So you want to talk about that.
The trend is blah, blah,
but this isn't really
the way things are going
to go because of this.
And take people to
the thought process.
That really captivates clients
and prospects, in my view.
I'm saying be
on-trend, but you have
to have a different twist to it.
You have to have the
Google perspective that's
going to be smarter and a little
different than the hoi polloi.
So that's what you want to do.
Always be relevant.
And another thing, you can slice
and dice this content report
that LinkedIn is cranking
out by the C-suite.
What are the most read
and passed along articles
that they're doing?
And so this is kind of
a quick read to see--
and it's very different than
the auto industry and et
cetera, et cetera.
It can be very
helpful giving you
an idea of a dialogue to have
and a conversation to have.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
How do we know about these
new things in LinkedIn?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Well,
I just found out about it
on the LinkedIn publicity.
But it's being given to
your marketing department,
so your marketing
department has it.
AUDIENCE: They're failing us.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I don't know.
I don't know your
marketing area.
Because I was researching that.
I found this because it's new
and they're publicizing it.
And as I said, they're
really going after the sales
marketplace, so they're
developing a lot of tools.
Because I know people
in recruitment before,
and they just love the LinkedIn,
and they made tons of money
off that.
But they're providing
some very useful tools.
They publicized a lot
of this on the internet,
but they're giving the
detailed-- they're not
giving the exact scores except
to the specific companies,
but they're giving
these reports.
But marketing has got
to be providing you
with this kind of information,
because it's very valuable.
Because they're slicing
and dicing it by C-suite,
by industry, by other functions.
So it can be very, very useful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Because they're
giving it to the marketing
people right now.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
They just launched it
two or three weeks ago.
They publicized it.
That's where I got
these charts from.
They just launched it
in March, open launch,
but they're giving it to
the marketing department.
So you have to get it from them.
Always be up-to-date.
And here's another feature.
You can customize what the feed
is that you get on your updates
so that you only get
certain kinds of things.
You can indicate the
kind of information
that you want to
receive when clients
are changing their profile or
linking up with a sales rep
at a competitor.
Because you don't want
necessarily everything there,
or else you've just got
too much information.
It's not that useful.
But you can make it so
you're up-to-date on who
the people, the clients,
and the prospects
that you're following
any news to them that
might be useful for you.
You always want to be helping.
Really social selling is more
about helping than selling.
And so a key thing people
are looking for on LinkedIn
is really useful stuff.
And there's
research, if you look
at what works in
direct mail or works
online in terms of
what's passed along.
The number one thing
is useful information.
Here's what other people
are doing, important
new trends infecting
your industry.
So useful information is
what people are looking for,
particularly if it's new and
different that they haven't
seen a million other places.
Another thing-- and I'm sure
you've gotten emails like this,
and it works in the direct mail
area and the direct marketing
selling products as well as
with people-- is a teaser.
I forgot to tell you something,
or I have some surprising news,
or something like that.
People tend to open emails like
that because they're curious.
What's inside here?
So it gets opened.
A personal twist,
thinking of you,
here's a solution
to your problem,
people tend to open
those kind of emails.
You want to think of that.
So it's really not selling so
much as useful information.
Always be inviting.
I invited Chris.
He accepted.
But after you hook
up with somebody,
you get a notice
view Chris's profile.
You can click and view his
network, et cetera, et cetera.
So it always be inviting
people that you want to know.
And I bet there's a lot of
people that you know well,
colleagues from past companies.
And LinkedIn has
a lot of devices.
And I have a link at the
end of a detailed ebook--
because some of it's
complicated-- that details how
to do every little function you
might want to do on LinkedIn.
So you always want to be
inviting the right people
and inviting people that
could be your allies,
not necessarily people
that work in your industry,
but they could be other people
that could be part of your band
that you help each other
with ideas, et cetera.
And so what works in
a LinkedIn invite?
They have a default one.
I'd like you to join
my LinkedIn network.
But what a lot of people say
is they want it more personal
and are more likely to accept
if you make a personal.
Great meeting you at the
conference the other day.
Love to link.
I think we have a lot of similar
interests, blah, blah, blah.
So just short
couple of sentences.
As I say, I believe
in endorsing.
You want to endorse people,
and it's an easy way
to do clients and prospects.
And as I say, I
think, even though we
know that anybody can do it and
what the value of some of it
is, it looks good
on your profile
that you're a person that
people think well of.
You always want to
be recommending.
And the best way to
get a recommendation
is to write somebody
a recommendation.
And you can ask people if
they could recommend you.
Leave them an out, if they
have time, something like that.
Remind them of a
shared experience.
I think it helps with a lot of
people, because a lot of people
find writing onerous,
is to say, remember
we worked on this project?
And kind of give them the
copy so it's kind of a draft
so it's easy for them to do.
But the recommendations
count a lot for people,
if you're going after a lot
of clients and prospects.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
I think this is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: I
think this is great.
I think that you should
go after everyone who's
written an evaluation
of you and ask them.
And kind of give them draft
copy, because a lot of people
are inundated with work.
So kind of give them draft copy.
People that you worked on
a project together with,
remind them what the project
was and how the team worked
and the results and
sort of draft something.
People you worked together
with at other companies.
You want to have a robust list
of people that are recommending
you, because it's going
to help you sell in.
Because people think,
wow, these people
took the time to write
a recommendation.
That's really worth something.
You always want to be
liking and commenting,
particularly if clients or
prospects are posting something
on the internet.
And it's just like Facebook.
It's very easy to do.
But again, it's
touching someone.
Also, I'm going to talk
later about touchpoints.
But in the branding
world we think
about touchpoints, every place
a brand and a person touch.
And the whole game is to
increase the touchpoints,
to also have them
all consistent.
You don't want to have a bad
voicemail message that you
sound harried and a very
professional website.
You've got to have
it all work together.
But all that's valuable.
Always be connecting via Groups.
One of the things that's good
about a lot of these groups
is you can find the pain points.
There's always people
asking questions.
Does anyone have ideas on
how you solve this problem?
So answer questions, ask
questions, answer questions.
That can be a very good vehicle
for that kind of thing too.
And as I said earlier,
be easy to reach.
But Groups can be a
very interesting way
to get to know people
that they could
be potential clients and
prospects or allies of yours
to help each other.
Always be repurposing.
I had this conversation
with somebody earlier.
Everything that I
write a blog post on,
I do several different tweets on
it with different facets of it.
Somebody was saying if
I've posted an article,
should I also blog about it?
Yes, but write it a little
differently, a little different
headline, change a
couple sentences around.
Not everybody saw
the article, so you
want to use all these
different channels.
If you have a slide deck
that's resonating with clients,
think is there a way to make
five slides out of it that
would be OK in a public deck?
Because your competitors
could see it as well.
But you're looking
at your prospects.
And a lot of people are
very visually-oriented,
and there's a lot
of research that
shows that when you tell
a story with visuals
people remember it much
more than if they're just
reading an article.
So that's why a slide
thing with pictures
and a couple of sentences
can be very, very effective.
And I threw the top five
trends to transforming
retail or an infographic.
If you have a
complicated report,
you could do an infographic
on it, things like that.
You want to think creatively.
But everything I'd
repurpose into at least
four different ways or more.
And you always want to
be linking and tracking.
IBM got a lot of attention
with this social media campaign
that they developed for
their web-based services
which they weren't
selling that well.
It wasn't going
that well for them.
So they decided to do a social
media approach on LinkedIn.
And I don't know
what their base was,
but they claim in
the articles about it
that they increased sales
400% with social selling link.
And they linked it
to a landing page,
so they were able
to track easily
what resources people
were clicking on
and what was working,
and then they
made sure things
were followed up.
And there's another
study by HubSpot looking
at their clients and that
LinkedIn generated the highest
visitor lead conversion
rate, 2.74%, which
is a pretty good conversion
rate compared to Twitter
and Facebook, which
were all under 1%.
So this idea of using LinkedIn
and linking it to a landing
page where you can track leads
and then follow up on them
can be very, very valuable.
So we talked about
step one is brand,
step two is finding
the right people,
step three is engaging
them, and step four
is building relationships.
You want to build
relationships with people.
And a big thing in relationship
building in the branding world
and branding effectiveness is
what we call brand likeability,
building the
brand's personality.
And whatever the product is, we
write a personality statement
for the brand as if
it were a person,
because it makes it easy for all
the different creative people
that work on it.
And I always say
brands are like people,
and people are like brands.
And they measure a brand's
likeability with a Q Score,
and it measures both products,
in terms of likeability,
and people.
All the celebrities
have a Q Score.
And the celebrities
with the highest Q Score
make more money in
movie contracts.
They get asked to
endorse things.
And the likeability,
the Q Score can go down.
I'm sure Oscar Pistorius'
Q Score is underwater now.
And after the Olympics last
summer, he became very famous
and had received a
number of endorsements.
So I'm going to test your
ability to judge a Q Score.
Let's look at a few famous
people, and tell me,
who has the higher Q Score?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: You know what?
The guys say Angelina.
But who's got the higher--
AUDIENCE: Jen,
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Jen
has the higher Q Score.
Why is she more likable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Less provocative.
OK.
So she's more like the
girl next door, right?
What else about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: She
wasn't the other woman.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: She's
a sympathetic character.
She lost her guy.
She is.
But you know what?
It's funny,
likeability, we're going
to get into the factors
of that in a second.
Anyway, let's look at two guys.
Who's got the higher Q Score?
AUDIENCE: Tom Hanks.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: And why
is Tom Hanks more likable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah.
And likability's
important for people.
That's a key thing
as a salesperson.
Likeability and brand
personality are very key.
And what are the
factors in likeability
from a branding perspective?
You want to be attractive
but not too attractive
that people hate you.
You want to be similar
so people feel, gee,
I can relate to that person.
That's somebody I can imagine
having a glass of wine with
or a beer with.
So the similarity principle
is very powerful for brands.
The empathy principle, I
think the person feels and can
feel my pain and I
can understand them.
So the empathy
principle is important.
And also the
familiarity principle,
I'm aware who this person is.
People like things that are
more familiar, it turns out.
So that's one of
the reasons why you
want to build your
profile as well.
And Hanks seems very authentic.
You like the guy.
All right.
So in building relationships,
you want to always be clicking.
Social scientists call
sales people and others
that establish rapport quickly
with somebody clickers.
They have this ability
to find connection.
And it the big secret
of clickers are they
find similarity.
They find mutual
interests or something
in common with the other person.
Super sellers-- there's
been a lot of research
on this-- in a meeting
with prospects,
they get on the same
wavelength as the prospect,
and it's almost like
they're in sync.
In some of the tests, they think
at the same breathing patterns.
Whether it's consciously
or unconsciously,
they mimic the gestures
even of the prospect,
and they sort of get in
a mind meld with them.
And LinkedIn provides
you with a lot
of information about
clients and prospects
to build on this whole
bond of similarity.
Because similarity is
how people connect,
and it really contributes to
this whole likeability factor
that we were talking about.
And LinkedIn also tells you a
lot of ways you're connected,
similar skills that
you have with somebody,
similar people that you
know in common, groups.
And then they have this
on the right-hand panel
when you get to anyone.
So you could also mine
somebody's profile
for detailed
information, but also
they graphically show
you a lot of ideas.
You always want to
be connecting dots.
And I think that LinkedIn
provides a lot of information
of how to connect the dots,
of how people are connected
to other people, what
their interests are,
what their groups are, a
lot of things like that that
can be very useful in
terms of your pitch,
whether it's in
person or online.
This is a point that
Reid Hoffman made,
the CEO of LinkedIn his
book, "The Startup of You"
is this whole idea of giving
little gifts-- we're not
talking "gifts" in quotes
here-- sending an article,
offering advice,
making an introduction,
writing a rec on LinkedIn,
offering to critique something.
And there's a lot
of studies that
show that if you do at
least two of these gifts
before you make a sales pitch,
you'll be much more successful.
One seller started
out with 300 leads,
did this gifting
strategy, and then
reached out to introduce
yourself and link
and got a 65% return
rate, so now they're
on a first-level basis.
So it's an interesting
way to sort of build
that initial relationship.
I think we have a question here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just coming back to your
last slide for a minute,
it just prompted me to
think about something,
or another slide back.
In the selling
world, a lot of us
have accounts that are
direct competitors.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: What's any advice
you have on that, as far as
how you deal with-- It's
like dating multiple people.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: It can
be a lot of work
when you're trying to
put an article out there
to get one person thinking.
But it might be what their
direct competitor's doing.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Well, this is going to be
a problem in the business
that you're in.
And I think that
what you have to do
is come up with a communication
strategy-- what your brand is,
what you want to stand
for, the kind of articles
and things you're going to
put out there-- and realize it
doesn't matter if your
competitor sees them too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: OK.
Oh, I see.
I see.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I'm thinking of it less
from the content I share.
I can figure that out
as far as, hey, this
is an interesting
article for either,
whether it's one of them
doing something well
or one of them doing
something poorly, or whatever.
But more like
managing connections,
like to Tom's points
earlier about Microsoft
being a competitor of ours, now
I'm talking more to the people
that I'm trying to engage
with and connect with.
I don't necessarily
want CIO at Staples
to also know that I'm having
active conversations with CMO
at Office Depot or somebody
at Walmart or somebody else.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Yeah,
but you can on Settings
disable letting people
know certain things,
if you want, like
connections that you make.
You can eliminate some of
that from the Notifications.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
So you can do that.
I don't know what else--
any other ideas here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Well,
because many of them
are insanely sensitive
to each other
and what the other one's
doing or not doing.
It's like everybody's scared
of-- so Lowe's and Walmart,
not direct competitors,
but they kind of
are watching what
each other are doing.
And I don't go out and
advertise that I'm actively
working with both of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It can work
both ways, I'm sure.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: It
can work both ways.
I'm just thinking too, when
I was a client perspective,
there were a lot of people--
ad agencies, for example,
can't have a
competitive account.
AUDIENCE: Right.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: So if
you're in an ad agency,
they're not going to handle
any of my competitors.
But there were other supplies
we dealt with, obviously,
that are meeting with-- but
I think it's changing a lot,
because I think historically
a lot of executives--
and I would never mention
it in a meeting, obviously.
You've got to downplay it.
But I don't think you can
worry about it too much.
You can eliminate certain
things from your Settings.
AUDIENCE: It just
becomes a full-time job.
It's like Facebook, right?
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: You can say, oh, you
can go put friends in groups--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right
AUDIENCE: --the idea of brand.
Because if your brand is such
that you are really an ultra
connector and you're
using this as a tool
and it's really--
because if you only
have a couple of connections
and they're competitors
with each other,
that feel sensitive,
like you're choosing those two
companies, versus if you're
really active in a very
specific way where it's
your brand, whether it's the
maverick or the other things.
I think that can lend itself
so that when someone sees it
and they see that, oh,
he's connecting there too
or he's in this group
that they're in,
then it feels more authentic,
like, hey, look, this is me.
I do this socially.
You need to make it so that
that is your brand so that it
doesn't feel like you're
sharing secrets across.
It's more I share all
this stuff publicly.
For me, I want to try to
get this where it is public
that I-- if you want to
see that I'm connecting
with new people, great, see it.
Know that the
information is public.
Because the other thing is
that even if you change privacy
settings, we all know that
privacy settings change really
frequently.
So if you put
information out there,
know that it is in the public
domain the moment it gets out.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
I think it's a
whole new world now,
and I think this is
part of doing business
in the modern world.
You've already got
Google brand behind you.
That's very, very powerful.
You want to build a strong
enough brand that they
want to work with
you and they feel
that they're getting
the attention from you,
that they're getting your
smarts and your unique selling
proposition, however
you've defined that.
And I think that's what
it's all about today.
Because I think people want
to work with the best talent
that they feel comfortable
with, that they feel they get
outstanding service
from, et cetera.
Any other thoughts?
Has anyone had an experience or
have you had an experience with
a client saying, I don't like
that you're-- how do you handle
that?
AUDIENCE: What I was
going to go back to
is at a higher level separating
you are your persona at Google,
and then you're
outside of Google.
We're trained, there's
a lot of things
that we know that are
internal to our company.
So you also have to be
very careful with when
you go posting stuff and what
you're putting out there,
it's outside of the company.
And I think that maybe there
hasn't been enough thought
given to the internal
versus the external
and then how you
bridge that gap.
And I've struggled
with that too.
Because just like if you
have two competitors, how
do you share information
in the right way,
you can also share
too much out there,
and you can have challenges.
So you just have to give it a
lot of thought and make sure
that it's--
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Can you give us
an example of the decision
making in what you shared?
AUDIENCE: When I was dealing
with GE in a past life,
GE is ultra worried
about any information
about them being shared.
And we were talking to
Beth Comstock, the lady who
you had up there, the
CMO of General Electric,
and she came back-- she's
very much into social media--
to one of my colleagues.
She said that's actually
an internal GE thing.
We don't want that spoken
about in the social.
And she called LinkedIn
and had it taken down.
So it was a big deal, and our
team got chastised for it.
So you do need to
be a little bit--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: You
need to be very careful
with clients about
things like that.
What can we say?
Make sure they've
seen it before.
Hey, I'm going to post this,
and are you comfortable with it?
Because a lot of cultures
are like a GE culture.
It's more traditional, and
they're very, very concerned
about proprietary information.
But part of your job is we value
that your information's private
and the trust, the
trusted adviser.
AUDIENCE: One of the
questions I have is just
taking a step back.
So I understand the importance
of getting your brand
out there.
Also, the two years
before I was here,
I was doing social
media management.
And we went from 300 likes to
3 million likes on Facebook,
right?
And my boss was
always, OK, great.
How is this making us money?
How is this
translating into sales?
I'm like, but we
have so many likes.
The question is, what sort of--
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Well, that's
why I was showing the IBM
story with the tracking page.
AUDIENCE: Right.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
Social media is so new
that a key measurement is
this whole idea of engagement.
And how do you
measure engagement?
And it's a thorny problem
in the whole branding world.
How do you measure that?
But the big thing that
people are trying to do now
is link it with a
landing page so they
can track new leads, what
kind of communications
they're giving to
that potential lead,
and then tracking conversion
that it became a client.
Now then there's the
question of existing clients.
Again, it's this whole idea if
you believe the whole branding
bible that you want to have
meaningful touchpoints,
and you want to have
consistent, ongoing touchpoints.
And there's a lot of
reasons advertisers
feel this is valuable, so that
everything you communicate
to the client is on-brand and
on-strategy and consistent
and that it's ongoing, that
you keep the relation--
and it's a way of augmenting
the personal relationship,
how many times you call
the client or prospect.
But the thing that
they're trying to do
is this whole tracking.
It's a new area.
And that's where they're trying
to get leads to a landing page,
so then you contract conversion
and things like that.
So that's how
you're making money.
And I guess as I say, it's a
whole new area of branding.
So it's this whole
thing of what are
the other ways we can
measure the effectiveness?
So it's in
development right now.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
how to speak into these.
OK.
CATHERINE KAPUTA:
That's working.
AUDIENCE: I think
that also goes back
to what Ketan was saying
with campaigning and emails.
Once we've done all of this
and we've established ourselves
on LinkedIn, whether
or not Erin thinks
we have credible profiles,
but as long as prospects do,
Kira and I found that
we could use InMails
as a way to establish
the relationship
and set up a meeting and kind of
nurture that and go from there.
I don't want to say too much.
We're doing a presentation on
it to a few people in this room,
so I don't want to
speak too much on it.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: How were you
tracking the effectiveness?
Can you not destroy
your presentation
but give us some insight?
AUDIENCE: Well, of
course we're tracking
response rates and
the amount of meetings
that we set from the
outreach that we do
and then also tracking
how the connections change
from third-degree
to then first-degree
after sending one InMail.
And also it's been successful
connecting with people
that we've talked to in
the past, other prospects,
going out, connecting
with those,
and then seeing-- many of us
work within regions, right?
So if you're connected with
this many CIOs in your region,
it makes it easier to
send an InMail to a CIO
also in that region who perhaps
is connected to those two
you're already connected with.
So just kind of increasing
your credibility
through the connections
that you have has helped.
CATHERINE KAPUTA: Right.
Right.
Yeah.
And this also
gives you a vehicle
for ongoing communication.
So that's what
really starts making
a difference-- we talked
about being on-trend.
We talked about being
up-to-date-- figuring out
what's of interest and
periodically sending things
so that there's these
touches going on.
When you think of brands
that you do business with,
they'll send follow-up emails.
Then you'll get
something after that.
Thought you might be
interested in this.
So you want to do
a similar thing.
That's what eventually works
and keeps a relationship,
augments the kind of personal
touch that you can give.
All right.
So we were giving
the little gifts.
I know you're going to have
a presentation after this
on story, but you always
want to be telling stories.
Stories are sticky and
disguise the sales message.
And this is a whole big
message of branding.
You rarely see a commercial
that talks about really
what the product is and analyzes
it in any kind of rational way.
Really they wrap the
brands in stories.
They tell stories that
people connect with.
And you want to use stories
to tell about here's
a project that we
had from a client.
Here was the challenge.
And then tell a story.
And the best stories are
stories you can film.
You want to bring to life
so that people can imagine
they were there and the
challenges, the obstacles.
There's a lot of
different story formats.
The story format that I used
when I was telling that Barbara
Corcoran story in the beginning,
I could have just made
one slide and said here
are seven principles
that Barbara Corcoran displayed.
But no, I told the story
about her boyfriend
left her and this and
that and the other thing
and she wrote "The Corcoran
Report" and the Donald Trump
thing.
You want to build
it so people get
a sense of the different phases,
the struggle, the obstacles
and then how you solved
the problem at the end.
So you want to sort of bring
that whole thing to life.
And LinkedIn gives you a lot
of avenues with the updates,
so anybody can post an update.
You can do it in Groups.
You can make it anonymous,
a technology client
or a retail client, so not
mention a specific name,
if you want.
But tell a story that's related
to problems they're probably
facing and how it was solved
it how it was successful.
You always want to
be asking questions.
Questions are a very powerful
thing in advertising.
Because statements are
passive, but a question
begs involvement.
Ronald Reagan famously
asked the question
are you better off today
than you were four years ago.
Most people couldn't say
yes, and he got elected.
Questions can be
very provocative,
because it gets people thinking,
just like the story gets people
thinking about the story
and gets people all involved
in the story.
Questions get people involved.
When you just make
statements, we did this,
it doesn't really retain
in the memory the same way.
You always want to
be tracking contacts.
And LinkedIn has a tool.
I don't know if a lot of
people know about this,
but you can track
relationships or you
can make notes,
reminders, how you met.
You can tag them, put
different tags on people.
So you can go to
LinkedIn and bring up
all the people
with a similar tag.
Or you can transfer
your first-degree names
to a CRM system that you use
and like better to manage them.
But you want to be tracking
all these contacts.
And as I mentioned
earlier, branders
think of increasing
touchpoints, online, offline.
You want to leverage
your status updates.
We talked about repurposing.
You can make it public
plus Twitter, so anything
you update that it goes out
to the public plus Twitter
automatically.
You can also tag your
updates in the body of it,
@company or @user, user,
and it'll automatically
go to them as well.
If you have certain
clients or prospects
that you have permission
to use their name,
it's an easy way to keep
that touch going on.
And I think it's important
to-- how can you do all this
and keep your day job too?
So you always want
to be automating.
I see LinkedIn as the
center because there's
280 million members and growing.
It's the business site.
But leverage all
these other vehicles
that you have as well too.
G+ is good for Circles and
people that share similar
passions and interests.
Twitter I see as like a PR
thing, very short sentences.
You can link, as you know,
to other longer articles.
But it's a very
quick form of PR.
YouTube, videos.
Videos are very powerful.
Facebook, Pinterest
is about pinning.
I have a business where
it's not so visible.
But I have certain
slogans that I use.
If you don't brand
yourself, other people will.
But I put with an interesting
visual and put it on Pinterest.
So you always want to be
moving the brand forward.
You want to be current.
You want to be meaningful.
Multimedia, figure out the
different media you can use.
Consistent, ongoing,
and this whole idea
of having an
emotional connection.
And my final thought is you
always want to be visible.
Branding is always about
building visibility.
Social selling is about
building visibility, finding
the right people,
connecting with them,
building relationships.
And just like we talked about
there's a beauty premium,
there's a visibility
premium, both for products
and for people.
And people who are
visible, research
shows people think
they're better than people
who aren't that visible
in the industry.
And LinkedIn gives you a
vehicle for building visibility
and building connections with
your clients and prospects.
So I just threw this in.
This is a client's
story of, again,
branching out into areas
outside the IT department
for building business
and companies.
So the whole idea was
finding business leaders
outside IT, interacting,
delivering, and again,
this two-gift idea
or three-gift idea,
sending some
interesting articles,
sending some interesting
things that they
thought they would
be interested in.